so you guys have an interesting story
how you met up with a Hollywood producer
and it was less than favorable the first
time out was that correct yeah that's
mean not that we've met with Hollywood
producer but more so that are we were
represented by ICM and as a writer
Frances agent was in New York but there
was some people in Hollywood that were
interested in the story so they're the
ones who contacted our literary agent to
see if it was possible to look into the
possibility to work on hunting with my
brother ok and what were things that you
were noticing from these various
meetings where we talked to one
filmmaker who said it seemed like there
were always meetings about any more
meaning meaning to go meet you know yeah
there's a lot of that um the couple
things one they all love the title you
know honeymoon is my brother all right
it says it all you know it what what the
movie is going to be about and it's kind
of interesting and the filmmaker who
ultimately did buy it said oh I I bought
it on title you know he didn't read the
book but then you read the book and
found out that there was a lot more
there than you reckon for I think it's
interesting you know yes there's there's
always meetings and then more meetings
and often times people are very
enthusiastic in the beginning like these
with the title and its ass great story
but until you know Hollywood another
movie is successful and it goes down
that that road then everybody to want to
chase it and make the same thing you
know for instance the hangover we're all
we need to make the hangover where I'm
sure that was a probably a hard movie to
get made originally because whatever it
was but it's just it's it's funny how
Hollywood works one of our actor friends
who's now interviewing with agents and
things said you know as an actor you
want to go into those meetings you know
dressed up as a screenwriter you don't
wanna look like you're trying too hard
want to dress down a little bit but just
be a little more cagey are there things
you can recommend to people on how to
present yourself maybe keep some of your
cards to yourself I mean what what are
some of the tips that you can share well
the one interesting thing we were
interviewing some different
screenwriters in the in the beginning
stages and the one I guess maybe
mirroring the folks you're going to be
meeting with is possibly some good
advice because the person who we decided
to go with first thing he did was he
took a picture of himself when he was
backpacking in Europe and he put it on
the table there you go so we were like
that this kind of a guy we want to go
and so and he had also dog-eared and
posted noted our book you know
throughout and so it was obviously that
he'd been going in it was very tattered
the book so he had been going through it
over and over and over and over and so
that that's always huge from a writer's
perspective somebody's adapting your
work that they've actually read that
they've actually read the book and then
they're really into the the details that
that gives a rider a lot of comfort hmm
interesting um as far as the actual
writing process are you able to write at
home is that too distracting I know
we've talked to other people that say to
have to go somewhere yet I I can and I'm
not i can write in a crowded space
that's that's fine I've had to change my
writing schedule a little bit because I
got married and we have kids now and so
writing schedules go out the window and
you need to adjust it to your kids
schedule you know first I was adjusting
it to to nap times and now it's school
times so i uz but in general i tend to
edit in the mornings when i get up have
a cup of coffee do a crossword puzzle
get my mom going edit in the mornings
because that's when I think my mind is
clear on that front maybe go in and
patch up some some things have lunch do
something physical in the
ternoon then then I I do best writing
starting late afternoon and on in the
evening this is this is when I was
single obviously now that I'm married I
take what I can get but I does actually
follow along those lines somewhat I
think I'm more creative later in the day
and I think I'm more left brain earlier
in the morning yeah I had the same thing
I think it's the coffee as you notice
but do people recognize the two of you
on the street and what do they say
occasionally but you know it is just
like hey there's a honeymooning brothers
I saw you on Oprah or I saw you on you
know the Today Show or you for them you
know it's better like when we did our
first book signing in our small town
where we grew up Davis California where
you know I think seven hundred people
showed up to come to this book signing
event and buy the book and that was
probably the one day that really felt
the most like all right it's cool right
like rock stars so you do these book
clubs and and most of them are women
that attend what do they ask you what I
mean are there just specific things in
the book that they want to know about
what what is the main gist of what they
sort of the number one question we
always get is did you ever talk to Annie
the woman who dumped you d what happened
to Andy what happened and then I always
say you got to read the book you know
generally the the fans break down into
different categories there's there's the
book club person so that's a range but
like the people who come to the signings
and stuff and there's the travelers they
and they want to talk about travel
there's the dumpees or the dumpers and
the broken hearts and so I got a lot of
emails from people who said you know I
got I got dumped too we get a lot of
brothers and sisters and family members
including one time we're in chicago and
his
brother and sister word came to the
event and they said that they had
another brother who had passed away and
they weren't close to three of them they
were in their 30s they're young and they
sister gave the brother the copy of the
book and he said that the books really
help you know bring them together after
your brother's death so and then and
then we get a lot of seniors like who
love LaRue our grandmother and think
that she's really cool so it's a real
range no it's great for us because it
makes our events really interesting I
know it's tough for the publishers
because they want to put you in a niche
you know and your your your demographic
is you know this and one other thing
about the book clubs it's interesting to
see the variety of book clubs and you
know some are very serious and they have
their their questions typed out and you
know here's what we're going to be
asking you and others your we show up
and no one even talks about the book you
know everybody so you know enjoying
their their glass of wine or whatever
that you know the books in there they're
perfect to mention so it's kind of funny
the whole the whole spectrum of that do
you feel a sense of responsibility to
almost canceled people that have been
through sort of life shattering
situations and then they kind of look to
you to like you're the answer in some
sense it seems like it could be a heavy
build Phil I mean along the lines Franz
was mentioned about some of the emails
we get I don't maybe it's not that we're
we feel responsible to help people out
but if someone does we receive a lot of
emails so if somebody does send an email
and ask for advice on something or how
you did it or what you did we're very
good about responding to every single
one of them and we've received you know
probably over 3,000 emails from readers
but I think more so of us talking with
folks and individually counseling people
or whatever the feedback you get from
the emails shows that the book has
changed or transformed somebody's life
and that's
that's a huge reward I I try to say you
know when i hear from dumpees or people
just ended a relationship I never tried
to give him advice like hanging you know
like go back to him he know or tried
again but I the one thing I always say
to people is of all of the the folks who
I've met you know who've been dumped at
the altar left not one of them has ever
come back and said you know I wish that
relationship would have worked out
they've all gone on to you know better
relationships that are situations and so
I I try to tell people that that point
that I look you know I you'll get to
this point you know and you you will go
on to bigger and better things and but
it's still tough you know working their
way through that those early months we
always joked it if you've gone through a
tough breakup it's it should be required
that you know like six months after you
get to see that person again and then
you'll nine times out of ten you'll be
like yeah why did I waste so much time
and energy and mental space and
agonizing over this relationship where
you see him kneeling up you can forget
about all the bad I mean there's a
reason why it didn't work it didn't work
and why on earth would you want to be
with somebody when it's clear that it
didn't work